c'était une journée de commémoration en
indonésie les familles des victimes de
l'écrasement du boeing 737 max de la lnr
se sont rendus en mer pour se recueillir
des white sox à des milliers de
kilomètres de là le congrès américain
attendait le grand patron higuain de
pied ferme dans la salle silencieuse
d'autres familles endeuillées serré
contre elle et photos des êtres chers
disparus
le président de la commission du sénat
américain a tenu à souligner le triste
anniversaire est aussi l'écrasement du
737 max d'ethiopian airlines boss
jackson deux accidents qui auraient pu
être évitées boing boing et l'aef a à
doivent nous dire s'ils sont précipités
la certification du 737 max at il ajouté
charest est pris entre schori le
dirigeant de boeing a présenté ses
excuses et reconnu des erreurs
cela n'a pas suffi aux parlementaires
tour à tour ils ont accusé la direction
de boeing d'avoir dissimulé des missives
de pilote que le logiciel automatique de
pilotage le mk inquiétait d'avoir voulu
déjouer l' agence fédérale de l'aviation
et même d'être de mèche avec elle la
parution a atteint son paroxysme lorsque
lé sénateur du connecticut a demandé aux
familles endeuillées de ce levier de
sprites manager des bulls never had et
les pilotes n'avaient aucune chance ces
êtres chers non plus ils voyageaient à
bord de certains vols en at il dit ému
on prouver bon il affirme avoir apporté
des améliorations les analystes
dénoncent une vaste opération de
relations publiques
le problème de conception de l'avion
sont toujours là alors on peut faire
toutes ces mises en scène on peut faire
toutes là mais recule par du monde
on est quand même face à un problème qui
est insoluble a encore aujourd'hui un
problème coûteux aussi pour les
compagnies aériennes qui s'attendent à
ce que les boeing 737 max reprennent du
service l'an prochain
ici maxime bertrand radio canada moreira